-Karl?
-KARL: Yeah?
Do you like the, uh,
the Pierce deal?
I do. I do, yes.
Yeah. Oh, yeah.
(LOGAN ROY CHUCKLES) Bullshit.
Boar on the floor.
(KARL SCOFFS)
LOGAN: Hey!
-(CHUCKLES) Okay.
-It's a game.
In the corner, over there.
Stand there.
-Go, go, go, go, go.
-(KARL LAUGHS)
All right. (SIGHS)
Tom?
-Me?
-Yeah.
-Uh, Pierce?
Um...
Well, there's a lot of...
(CLEARS THROAT)
factors, and...
but yes. I personally--
I like it. I like it.
Boar on the floor over there.
Gerri, stand up.
Stand up!
Pierce?
Couldn't tell you.
Couldn't tell you. Don't know.
-Have you played it before?
-No!
Well, actually, I...
To be perfectly honest,
I've-- I've had a few doubts.
LOGAN: Honesty.
You see, everybody?
Do you see?
Honesty.
Greg, stand up.
Did you get any orders
from my brother,
the fuckin' Conscience
of the Prairies?
-Me?
-LOGAN: Yeah.
I... don't... Uh...
Yeah. I-- 'Cause I--
(STAMMERS)
I've had some doubts too.
Oh? Fucking doubter.
Over there.
But the rules are that you're
spared if you tell the truth,
-and I just told you the truth!
-Oh, oh! There are rules?
-GREG HIRSCH: Right?
-Do you know something, Greg?
There are no fucking rules.
(WHISPERS) Over there.
GREG: Okay. (LAUGHS NERVOUSLY)
(ROMAN ROY CHUCKLES)
LOGAN: Roman!
I like it for real, Dad,
-I wanna help--
-Stand the fuck up.
Um, okay.
Kendall took a call
from the biographer.
We all got a call, Rome.
Okay, yes, but you--
See, he seemed like
he wanted to actually
talk to her.
To smoke you out for Dad.
What? Fuck you. Why'd you get
to smoke me out?
I was smokin' you out.
Why don't you tell us
about your mystery call?
The phone call?
Uh, yeah. It was Frank.
He meant to call you.
He wants to know if the plan to
overthrow Dad
is still happening.
Someone spiked Pierce.
Which one of you boars
did it?
-Tom!
-Yes?
Sit on the floor!
It's fun.
-Seriously?
-Yeah, it's a game!
-Boar on the floor!
-TOM WAMBSGANS:
I really-- I feel--
LOGAN: Get down!
Boar on the floor.
Kendall, bring the troops.
ALL: (CHANTING)
Boar on the floor.
-Get down!
-ALL: Boar on the floor.
-Greg! On the floor, boar.
-(CHANTING CONTINUES)
-Come on, Frank!
Why am I in this?
How the fuck would I know, Greg?
You think I have a rational
explanation for this?
Frank! Feed the piggies,
guests of honor!
That's it. Boar on the floor!
ALL: Boar on the floor!
Oink for your sausages,
piggies. Shh. Shh. Shh.
piggies. Oink.
KARL: Oh, Jesus Christ.
Oink for your sausage, Tom.
Oink.
-LOGAN: No.
-(TOM SNORTING)
No half-hearted oink.
I want full-bodied oinks.
-I'm not doing it.
-KARL: Oink, oink, oink.
On the count of three,
the last piggy to eat
a sausage is the mole.
That doesn't seem like
a very good system...
Who spoke to Pantsil?
(WHISPERING) Please.
Hey!
Crawl in a circle
and close your eyes.
-(LAUGHTER)
-Three...
Greg, oink.
(GREG SNORTS)
Two...
(GREG, TOM AND KARL SNORTING
AND OINKING)
One...
(CHEERING AND LAUGHING)
Eat the sausage, Tom!
-TOM: I got it!
-(JEERING)
(SHOUTING AND CLAMORING)
GREG: It's my fucking sausage!
MAN 1: Take it out of his hand!
MAN 2: Come on!
Karl stole my sausage!
Karl stole my sausage.
Too effing slow.
I'll get you your booby prize.
Eat up, piggies.
ROMAN: I believe he said
"Eat up, piggies."
I wanna see you little
piggy fucks eat. Eat it.
Indemnification,
you fuckin' dummy.
Wh-- You fucking serious?
How old are you?
Give me back my fucking phone.
-Huh? What are you hiding?
-What are you-- Wh-- Hiding?
Nothing. Give me back
my fucking phone.
-What's your code?
-Are you fucking serious?
-Yeah. What's your--
-My code? Uh, my code is,
um, fuck you-- What?
(KENDALL AND ROMAN
ARGUING INDISTINCTLY)
Okay, you got it. All right?
Happy? There's nothing in there.